okay you the Palestine University C
things you know what they are so there
was not too long ago there were pal mus
going to the University campus setting
up staying there overnight until
un accept from the demand to a formal
protest okay so one what's your view on
their
your view on the effect first I'm not
the person that ask by my view I'm no
one what the SCH said
not go and there's other ways that you
can do but that's what the schol
understand and uh you know one of the
the biggest uh protest in the history of
Brit was against the invasion of Iraq I
over 1 million people came out say
day
chur I don't believe that people give
you a weapon to fight them against your
opponents will never give you a weapon
in order to overpower
him protest
[Music]
ially does not work
no we Muslims are looking for any
solution except
going cuz why like a brother was
speaking to me
yesterday what you said is right I was
in
a so he said to me he said once he was
in a protest he said he looked back and
there were like thousands of people he
said when I was in the M when he was in
the M for prayer for prayer there was
only two rooms
said imagine the amount of people they
were protest in
the you know Allah
said Allah will never change the state
of people until they change themselves
this is the reality but now you know
subh we don't want to go byan andah and
if someone call us now look what the
messenger of Allah said will come a time
when a liar will behold as a truful
person now when you call people to they
call you zist
when they
you why the zist know that the solution
for the Muslims to have a victory by
going back to Quan andah according to
the abilities doesn't mean they're going
to become perfect you
understand
abilities seen vide for years from the
states you're from the States United
Snakes yeah
honestly good seeing you man take care
blesso yeah solution
go that's why you know Allah narrated
The Story of the prophets in the Quran
for reason do you know that there were
three
prophets under the occupation of ala of
the Romans three prophets they were
living in AA that was occupied by the
Romans
and these three prophets they did not
fight who are
they and
cousin
and and cousin so there were three
Prophet under the Roman Empire oh yeah
and the Roman Empire was in control of
Palestine yes so those prophets and
Messengers why did not fight why they
allow the
Romans to
control maybe some people must
be yes I want answer from the people who
they mo ofnah when they tell solution at
the
there the Jews now uncle is the prophet
imagine Jesus and Zakaria and Y John
both them were under the occupation of
the Roman Empire in Palestine and they
didn't do nothing they give da of course
oh yeah but they didn't fight why maybe
maybe they were not as as 1 year in
makah said that to some people they say
you're ACC course to Jesus